to take it from having goddamn FBI cases
and to being the representative of
the bills to Byron Brown declaring
Conway the machine day in
Buffalo that feel like it's insane you
know that's the craziest in the
world it's a whole new life that's why
everybody that's why everybody around
you can't understand it because they not
in your shoes but this is literally a
whole new life when you come from that
you come from the the street the
real the real in tune with it though you
know what I'm saying not glorifying it
nothing but just drawing Spectrum just
being really in it you know what I'm
saying having three felonies or being
through those raids
and marrying a girl who who was with me
through all of that you feel what I'm
saying so it's like it's a different
life to to to see this and I'm
happy for everybody I'm happy for Conway
I'm happy for Westside gun Manan this
is nuts you get